this is a production of Cornell
University
I'm standing here next to Concord grape
vines and this was originally people
thought that Concord was Vitus lebra ska
and then they realized it wasn't and it
was reclassified so what is Nebraska is
a wild forest that grows at in eastern
Massachusetts it smells so much like
pocket
so lots of growth big leaves green
leaves white thunder undersized and that
tells me this is a juicer and when we
look underneath we can see that there
are clusters under here so here is a
nice Concord cluster you can see it's a
good size and the berries are quite a
good size too and these are just about
ripe we'll start putting them in until
now one of the things we see with what
we call these lebretia cultivars is that
there what was its lipstick so if we
push on one of the berries we can
actually make the entire flesh pop out
the berries and get rid of it and so
that slips gig and that also tells us
that this is likely Allah brusca type
cultivar as well and again big cluster
big berries and if you smell it
that smells exactly like Concord grape
juice so that's how I know that this is
a Vitus lebra skintight cultivar and is
usually used fruit juice crypts
you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu